wo ist dein weg
[Musik]
das ist wirklich nicht schwer
du gehst zur bank und wünscht einen
guten tag ich heiße gonzales wenn ich
möchte bitte ein konto eröffnen
das ist alles nicht ganz die bank wir
wissen woher du kommst
ich komme aus spanien aus wie ja ja ja
die antwort kannst du mittlerweile im
schlaf
dann musst du ein formular ausfüllen
dein geburtsdatum deine adresse
du kannst das ja die schraube einfach
ich schreibe einfach die adresse von
telara ja das ist in ordnung
dann fragen sie sich vielleicht wie du
arbeitest die bank findet ist natürlich
besser wenn ein festes einkommen hast
kann nicht sagen dass ich noch keinen
job habe ja das ist okay gut dann kann
ich ein konto eröffnet ja und wenn es
ein problem gibt rufst du mich einfach
ab okay okay okay